what's going on reject nature and we're
gonna watch superman and lois episode
two today really love the first episode
excited to see what they got in store as
the story progresses you guys should go
ahead hit that like button
subscribe if you haven't done so already
any one of those really helped the
algorithm out and getting this video
promoted of course dude got to mention
this is reaction highlights full length
reaction watch how long we've seen with
the time code roll over at our patreon
page thank you to everyone who's become
a patreon eject you guys
rock recover so many shows over there
we're at the same tier you get the
option for reaction highlights and watch
along
included it means so much to have you
here i got to thank a new gentleman here
named pratham i think that's how you say
his name he's going to be editing these
reaction highlights for us i think he'll
do a good job he hits people like jaby
kuwait from time to time as well
anywho let's get into action people
what can you say about leaving a place
you loved
[Music]
even the music is high quality
just leave the wrench save a lot of
money on ladders here
i only got two of the ap classes i want
and they put me in spanish instead of
french
damn it that's every one of jordan's
lines yeah damn it
spanish is stupid
and to live in a safer place for me to
teach you about your powers and
the reason you have them what do i need
to learn i'm a little stronger so what
you're a lot it's got laser eyes yeah
that explosion last week so what
so i'm just not gonna go to school damn
it
[Laughter]
yeah i thought coming here would be a
chance to start over but i guess i'm
just gonna be a freak like always
feels like home already jordan you got
super powers
you're not even a little bit psyched
about that that stranger in the war suit
really got to you didn't he
what if he knows about us the boys where
we live my dad's working on it
your dad relies on him
it's a big little circle
who's the composer for this ah yeah i'm
gonna learn that name
where is it what is what the kryptonite
i can't get it anymore
[Music]
kello before he dusted this well what he
did to mine
predictor over here
[Music]
it's good you're good you're good at tv
well i think it has something more to do
with the
crisis on infinite earth screw i mean
that's what i said right
[Laughter]
how exactly did i get this right
try to keep an open mind okay does clark
need that beanie
it's a way of bonding with jordan why do
we need these big winter jackets
are we flying somewhere i kind of have
to hold on okay
oh that's cool we get to go flying with
dad
and i have to go to school no
jonathan don't get jealous although i
would be completely jealous if i was in
your shoes
oh hey uh hey um hey hey
kiss her i'm gonna start quarterback
i'm all right too bad we already got a
qb we'll see how you do with our offense
some people think it's tough to learn
that's a diverse group of bullies
it's really nice a guy an asian guy and
a white guy all it's awesome
anybody can victimize somebody
oh definitely should have worn better
shoes
you suck
[Music]
fortress it's gonna take me a while to
get used to how good this show looks
i know because you don't expect this
quality effects are so good
maybe this place can help you the same
way and help me
this place said that your sons wouldn't
have powers that's the thing
this place is a liar think of it as a
computer drive
that contains the entire history of
krypton
your family history begins in krypton's
second largest city look at him smiling
i know over something that's not
depressing
actual wonder i did hear that morgan
edge was in
supergirl but they got a different actor
for this one
okay just further establishing that this
is its own thing
with some slight tie-ins hey lois hey
lana it's me and my abusive husband you
know what
you should all come tomorrow for a
barbecue
hey look he looks down our home was lost
forever one-third of superman's stories
are dedicated to explaining krypton
going away
you know it's it's the bruce's parents
dying of the superman world
this is your grandfather the man you're
named after unlikely thought
father he's manifesting abilities it is
possible for us to further
our kryptonian heritage after all
you know he does look like his dad that
he
oh no his game's off his game's off no
he can't
hear me anymore you'll get powers
i promise you man i promise you maybe by
season two
it's way better than therapy just go go
to the fortress to solitude once a week
daddy said
so i'll stay without me uh you know it
was
a lot better actually i think we should
have done this a long time ago shut up
oh i wouldn't even joke with jordan like
that
laser you
this time he came in a ship so he
brought more than just a warship with
him
but my guys were able to assign this
thing a resonance identifier
goes airborne again we got him by we
got him woody what do you mean exactly
check it out city council meeting hey
sarah hi
all right jonathan i'm really sorry
about timmy and
the playbook it's all good i got one now
so it's cool
[Music]
so they both into her now
you're lois lane and you're oh chrissy
buffo i've been
wanting to introduce myself the last few
days but i totally chickened out
a fellow journalist marvel because that
came to cover this
not that there's much news to ever cover
at these things
um meth dads blowing up their children
from the last episode pocket explosion
at least
ladies and gentlemen morgan edge
you can have anything you desire
wish you must wish
[Laughter]
still looking for the simple life as
those days are gone clark
canceled years ago let me know when you
find the show why'd you move the family
here
jordan's got no chance of fitting in
with kids here
damn you are like you don't like this
family
he just wants clark all to himself
he told the boys you're superman oh
it's right you ruined their childhood
clark
this is gonna keep my family together no
clark i'm gonna tear it apart
whose side are you
he's the real i just wanted you to
invite me to come live with you
hello i want it lonely in metropolis
from entry level to tradesmen we're
estimating around 600.
so if there are no more questions put it
up lois
yep that jobs number you say is
an estimate that's right miss lane it's
difficult to guarantee an exact figure
so is there a number that's more
feasible
because i would hate for what happened
in new carthage to happen here
don't participate in civic discourse i
thought those minds would be fruitful
save this town and improve its
lives
[Applause]
yeah that's what we want to hear that's
right yeah right here
like what you're saying though
smallville
isn't the place to take a risk right now
no screw you lois
get out of town
oh he's smart he's going to turn the
people against her yeah
with his charm
which you guys don't know is lex is
blasting that music in this [ __ ]
i'm also a dj
oh here we go what do you want
you go why
what did i do to you it wasn't just me
you destroyed my whole planet
wow whoa superman of steel vibes
damn wow
i got that crash zoom
yes
i love this so much i love the action
oh whoa
i know you can hear the bomb in my ship
people are gonna get hurt
take him make a choice
always for the people
yo this [ __ ] is so good it's
so good
ah
that's twice in a row you're falling
from space man
that crater i take some steps today
coach
kent i want you on the book learning the
offense i think if you just put me out
there
i can show you what i can do
oh they let him pass yeah i don't know
much about football
i don't leave it at that
[Laughter]
i've been on guys like this before this
was the worst time for someone like this
to be showing up
right when you moved your family to
smallville when's it every good time
clark
dad knows figured it out the other night
what do you say
oh you know just that we're making the
biggest mistake of our lives see now i
know we're on the right track
[Laughter]
it is about an article i am working on
about morgan edge
i thought you weren't getting involved
yes but then he started spelling this bs
about helping the town
morgan edge is a corporate vampire you
remember that edge owns the planet
great great way to kick that out the
smallville gazette
yeah dang i'm serious clark i'm getting
this
gut feeling that this is one of the
reasons i was supposed to come to
smallville
you see his look oh
lois just be a housewife that's what the
people want that's you're just
bored god
that was a joke everyone
clarified scary these days
absolutely rooting for lois to be a full
kid
jonathan you're a really great brother
you know that
tall i know how much you gave up by
saying yes to coming here
your whole life's in metropolis your
girlfriend's there you and i both had
lives we left behind
i really like that kid i know i think
he's like
really good really natural yeah the
photo nucleic effect appears to be
insignificant and significant he doesn't
even have 100 to your strength
test them again human dna is just too
limiting
damn lois this is a true villain of the
show
grandfather doesn't support him his
father doesn't support him
damn it damn it this fortress sucks
dude that ship and ai have been doubting
you since day one jordan don't worry
leave me alone you need people to doubt
you to motivate
what happened at the fortress i guess we
found out what i always do i'm not
special
baby have another bad day screw you
up i got a chat
don draper over here kiss sarah so now
her dick boyfriend
and the entire team are out to get me
that's why you didn't get the playbook
yeah
genius i guess super perception isn't
one of the powers oh
damn we moved here to be closer as a
family
and we got invited to this dinner as a
family and we are going as a family damn
damn lois mom of the year
[Laughter]
you made it sorry we're late
drinking the beer chewing gum thinking
about all those jobs
[Laughter]
hey i'm gonna come find you in a bit i
want to hear about practice okay
he's so good at playing both clark and
superman he's like so good at it
like you're not even thinking about
superman when he's just chlorinated he's
so good at it
he changed it he changed my story it's
like a pro edge fluff piece
i can't let him do this we're calling
the department of defense
lois lane needs her to reject it
lois ladies back up
[Music]
damn homeboy just shows up straight at
the department of defense
it's your dad he's in the dod i'll
explain why
if you're gone if you're back soon
enough you might not even notice
god's music is so good i know right
that's not gonna go good for you you
know i'm waiting for one cop of property
to go
guns aren't gonna help so why are we
even trying
we gotta do something they're just gonna
establish that the guns don't work
he's targeting him specifically i think
he is
where the hell is superman
[Music]
oh it's badass it looks right at the
camera
yeah signal lost
[Applause]
wow oh damn you're far too aggressive
superman stop calling him that he's not
one of us sam
and you don't trust him either because
you know what he is oh how fascinating
you have to help me save your planet
[Music]
oh
back back to space
one more time
[Music]
wow so cool
knew it
just too easy too easy
did you get the stranger getting closer
do you think we made a mistake by moving
here
actually i don't you just have a lot of
questions to answer
like what are you going to do about the
planet i don't know
don't become a screenwriter lady
and i know this family is closer this
week than we were last week
so it's okay if we've got a lot of
questions we're gonna find the answers
together
hmm no
all right i'll talk to you tomorrow okay
good night
superman just like um fly him over there
once in a while jonathan yeah yeah
that's what i keep thinking is like he
knows just take him still
you were right before you moved here for
me and i never even thanked you
i agree did you ever find out if you're
half kryptonian or what and according to
holograms
so honestly i really i don't care what
some stupid hologram said you're my twin
brother i know you're better than anyone
you're different now okay something
happened
no one else is going to help you figure
out what that is i will
oh dude
jonathan you're super you're the best
part
you don't even have powers the glue that
holds his family together
what's going on i'm choosing my favorite
i'm putting together a team
i've been gone a lot in your lives now i
can't just
abandon the world but i can't abandon
you two either
it's gonna take me some time to figure
out how to be better at both but i will
ah they are gonna abuse that
so i can go to school we have to keep an
eye on
your powers yes you can go where's mom
oh she uh she had a thing
just gonna go kick ass at the daily
planet
you rewrote my story i merely
corrected what was wrong miss lane i
won't have my paper printing this kind
of nonsense
that's what i thought oh [ __ ] she gonna
quit
what's this that is the best writing i
have done
you're badass that assistant's gonna
quit too
smallville gazette here we come
you hope it made you who you are sure
her boyfriend's going to be happy about
that
he's going to be so pleasant at school
7734. someone in the comments tell me
what that means
pushed you out of your comfort zone
and gave you the strength to demand
better
yes so bad after that you're so cool
lois
i love you marry me yeah yeah there you
go
take children except for jordan
hello the child
well it's yours now hope we get some
crazy boss oh
lois i'm guessing you read my article
that was in the daily planet
didn't really read like you because it
wasn't oh
this is what i wrote yeah yeah
yeah publisher [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
goliath
okay if i publish this you'll probably
get fired and i can't be a response oh
no
i already quit when can you start
hello it's gonna be the most woke
newspaper
ever it's just two chicks
it will take some time to locate the
proper materials
guess we'll go find what we need he's
good
homelander no
yes
7734 also looks like hell
[Music]
good [ __ ] good [ __ ] another solid
installment if you ask me
damn good stuff i don't remember the
crossovers all too well but i
i have a vague memory in my head
about there being a black suit superman
played by
tyler in one of the crossovers i think
it was the one that aired on supergirl
which would make sense
so yeah there was an evil superman in
that version i don't remember what the
conclusion of that is i'm pleased i
encourage you guys
to give feedback and comments
that help explain things my mind is
telling me that that's
the superman that we saw in the
crossover that we were watching in
luther's flashback here that would make
sense especially for tying it all in
if luther comes from that world and he
has this negative association
the least superman is not my superman
but i love that you know like it's such
a great
extra layer to add into here and then to
have it be combined
already with lois's father having doubts
about everything that's going on with
clark slash superman
and the whole family like in the last
episode he's coming down hard on lois
for not letting superman be a superman
and this one
he's coming down on clark for not being
a good enough
parental figure and not looking out for
his kids
too much of a parental video yeah not
enough just only superman
and because clark was opposing him in
this episode you can see a version where
you know like i don't think lois's dad's
gonna be like oh yeah no this this guy's
definitely right because clearly
from the whole perspective of lois's dad
whose name i can't remember i'm just
going to keep on lowe's dad
no he's having his doubts about clark's
choices lately
and i don't think he would turn on clark
at least anytime soon
but i think with enough of the
manipulation and explanation especially
if he has this conversation with luther
maybe he starts to turn against him you
know or the world versus superman now
when this earthman superman's already a
good guy it's planning the seeds for
some awesome
conflicts that could arise between clark
superman
luther and lois's dad all that sounds
cool and it goes without saying the
actions is freaking awesome
this this whole episode had me going
sweet too that's good
drama sweet that's good drama
yeah the best of both worlds across the
board it feels like because yeah the
realization of the worlds alone and then
the action sequences like when he's
fighting lex through the woods and stuff
like that like it looked
incredible like way better than network
television levels and i mean i'm
constantly in awe even of the music and
stuff like that and yeah i love that
element of
introducing just the nugget of doubt in
papa lane's mind you know to grow that
because yeah i like that it's taking its
time in a way that feels
plausible with lex and i like that we
get a couple little moments with him
personally just to
kind of see what he looks like and see
what his vibe is overall
him planting the seed with the whole
hell uh and back seven three four four
thing like for me who's not seen the
crossovers and stuff it is like hinting
at oh a much bigger world that makes me
actually curious about
those other things on the other side of
the multiversal wall
yeah they've done a good job with the
violence with luther because he's
he has his sonic blast power but no
one's getting like
bloodied up or obliterated and i can't
really recall in the last episode was
there anyone who actually
was murdered or even in this episode i
can't i think he murdered the guy at the
beginning but they look like they were
bad guys already
yeah i mean yeah i think it's just like
they're able to make it look
so sinister and painful gruesome yeah
it compensates for hopefully what is not
a lot of people being massacred because
that was the one thing that kind of
popped up in my head
during this episode was wait a minute
though you're causing like a lot of
havoc and you were just about to like
bomb a city a minute ago
even though that would you know go to
prove your point that superman is a
ruthless character but
but still but he i think he knew that
superman wouldn't choose
yeah but i'm like if he did what would
he have done he would have been like i'm
right
i called it call him back i knew you
blew it you're the evil one
you're a dick you let them die i just
sent the bomb yeah
i gave you the choice yeah it was all
you man i'm loving that later but
really it's it feels like it's like
clark and lois show first
yeah which i mean is great considering
the title
i i just think that's so interesting
because i don't know it kind of actually
feels like a solid 50
50. yeah it's so interwoven like
perfectly interwoven it's not like when
we're just with clark and lois or the
kids i'm like can you get back to some
superman [ __ ]
i don't feel that way and then when the
superman stuff happens it's so rewarding
i love how it does feel like it's
constantly feeling like an interference
in his life
yeah really like oh god please don't
ring the thing now for a barbecue
and it's not like clark is ever going i
don't want to go you know
you know he's not behaving like his son
you know he's not like
the world sucks yeah he doesn't have
that attitude but you could feel
the conflict they're trying to be like
there for his kids and then especially
with his kids now having powers
or at least one of them having a display
of powers how that creates conflict for
the guy
feeling like he has to be kind of a 24 7
dad but it's impossible for him they
have to balance
like their lifestyles are just so weird
they have weird lifestyles man
i mean it's neat now they're taking lois
out of the daily planet and putting here
here to work in the small town of
smallville one thing that i think
makes it feel a little bit less like a
cw show too the only thing that feels
like a cw
show to me is the uh the husband
too yeah who has that one note
he's always showing up like right in
time to catch lois saying something
about morgan edge or whatever
like catch a few words through his
peripheral i'm the typewriter it's about
morgan edge isn't it
right there with a laptop was the only
thing that felt like a cw show
but the rest i think part of the quality
that makes it elevated too
is you know with a lot of the shows on
network television they have their
designated sets for most things
yes you don't you don't feel like you
have a designated
set yeah yeah we're either at school or
anything yeah
or it's an action set piece in a
nondescript warehouse
yeah it seems like they got a lot
they're moving around quite a lot yeah
and i love that and the and the music
too is incredibly cinematic
from the touching wondrous tones that
you get when you're with
clark or the family to the heavy
tones and those those what is that that
instruments that they play for the
luther parts oh yeah
they're so like like something menacing
is just
like [ __ ] enveloping you in that
moment well they're all like so
synthesized and so like unnatural
sounding i love that you have yeah these
more naturalistic tones that rise up
when you're in smallville that kind of
hint toward the americana nostalgia of
that and then yeah when you cut to lex
it's like droning and foreboding droning
is the worst yeah it almost feels like
an alarm or something like that it was
like his footsteps
yeah exactly and it's like really
expressive in that way and it's one of
those things where i'll
catch it part way through and be like oh
wow like sometimes it's distracting to
notice the music but this just keeps
coming back to me like wow this is so
detailed and it's so expressive and it
seems to fit the scene so well it
doesn't feel stock you know
i have a very sneaking suspicion about
what's going on with jordan
i think he is a super boy prime which i
believe is the correct terminology the
bad
superboy i have a suspicion that jor-el
the ai version is intentionally trying
to
not hone in on his powers because i
think he suspects
that there's something malevolent that
could come from this guy and the show
keeps kind of saying
it i mean he's only jordan's only good
at the end of each one of these episodes
like he's moody and whiny and yes i
understand he's got mental health
conditions social anxiety disorder at
the same time though sometimes it
doesn't feel as layered as it can be
it just seems like everything it really
does just make him
sad or angry his scenes definitely
develop for me over time because when we
cut back to him there are times where
i'm like oh is this gonna start to get
annoying
but they always bring it back but it is
sort of like a mode that that character
seems to slip into by default
i mean i'm not gonna act like i i hate
the guy because i don't there are some
scenes that i really like what he's
doing
and i never feel like it's the
performer's fault
no because i have a feeling that what
they're doing with him is they're trying
to repress
what his capabilities are because i'm
like shit's just not adding up yeah him
saying like no your kids won't have
power it's not likely kate clearly has
powers
like clearly has powers yeah it just
happened spontaneously you know that's
it carl that's all you got to deal with
so somehow you just got to keep a
lookout for when it spontaneously
happened yeah
and if it happens to be spontaneously an
explosion like last time well it doesn't
really mean much
though it's not real powers man
yeah there's something kind of ominous
about the way jor-el's portrayal is here
he's got no warmth to him at all no no
and i know he's the ai but the ai
supposed to also embody kind of the
personality of
uh jorel and like i said i've seen like
two episodes of supergirl and only the
crossovers that feature supergirl and if
she's ever appeared in like flash or
something
like that's the most i've ever seen of
super girl so i don't know what the
portrayal
is of jorel entirely but yeah the vibe
that we're getting here is there's
something about him that
he's i think he knows more than he's
letting on the theme of this seems to
deal so much with father and son
family overall even down to the the one
note character of lana lang's
husband it seems all about protecting
the community and the family like his
motive seemed good and i think that's
one thing that seems other than
we got to see more of this morgan edge
character develop but everyone seems
pretty
layered in their motivations like luther
sure he's got like the evil music and he
comes across
evil and looks freaking evil but already
you're like well i totally get it
you know like that one flashback feel
the same way about
he's like determined yeah take him out
he's like sarah connor in here you know
yeah you can't trust him
i gotta be traumatized he's gonna be
evil you can't trust this guy
it's like it's not the same superman but
he's kind of in this dark
cyclical world of well i gotta still
to take my vengeance and my revenge and
wipe out the evil that is superman and i
like that i think that's refreshing to
have that for
a live-action lex luthor as well someone
who's not just businessman
or evil genius you know like this is a
very different take uh at least for live
action you know but like i keep saying
over kind of hopping around here the the
drama
is so well done i loved watching all of
the lois investigating and going to the
small town meeting and the gazette i was
charmed by all that
jonathan having to deal with how like he
didn't ask for any of this
and he played it so real that i think
that's what was so great about his
performance is he could have gone for
such a heavy defeated take
but it would feel kind of like too much
of a slingshot from
what he was like in the last episode the
character's naturally optimistic
he's naturally uh more of a positive guy
that's what i thought was later about it
he's obviously trying to maintain a
positive
head space while dealing with the most
negativity
he's ever had to deal with in his life
you know being isolated at school having
to deal with the fact that his brother's
getting the superhero treatment
not just isolated but also bullied at
school being away from his girlfriend
he's got a lot to deal with
and he made all this big sacrifice with
nom
they say to them like you know you made
the choice to come here but i'm like i
don't really feel like they had much of
a choice
yeah one of them said no yeah i remember
them saying like you'll have time to
think about it tonight but i don't
really recall them breeding much of a
choice in the matter
i do think that actor brings a lot of
warmth in his presence like i got a
little misty-eyed when he was talking
with jordan at the end like
i said there's so much of this this
theme seemed to be about protecting
and community family there's a lot of
love represented in this
show that is shot really dark and
there's a lot of dark things going on
here but there's a lot of love
uh all around which i think embodies the
theme of superman
of you know having to do acts of love
in the midst of darkness acts of love
and the struggle that you can go through
for those acts of love you're like how
hard love can be
sometimes yeah and dan that guy is so
good he's so good at playing
really good and superman he's so yeah
he's really natural at both and like you
said during the reaction like he could
switch between them both and i'm
effortlessly hooked into either one and
there's no scenes at all almost like
it was really credit to his performance
ability because even
during the action i'm never like oh did
he switch the stunt man in like you know
he's just the full
package for this and i gotta say too we
had some of our
worries about lois lane from the first
episode of i hope they really make her
feel more like a strong character and it
feels like it's her show too
and right away i'm like oh second
episode they already alleviated that
problem yeah like i'm excited to see
what happens
i was rooting for her she's a really
strong character in a way that feels
very natural like she doesn't
i don't know how do i communicate this
properly she has a kind of like a
sincere
serious take on the character she's not
like depressed and she's not without the
charisma
but there is this sense of like as a
journalist she has
this great quality of listening and
reacting
and a sense of empathy is always on
display
and just the body language and the eyes
of her performance i think she does a
great
wonderful job and i'm like i was even
trying by the gazette thing you know
like i
i i really like this show a lot i really
do
i just have my i was falling off of
every cw show for a reason
and so i have like my apprehensions but
that's only because of preconceived
notions but what we've gotten so far i'm
like i don't know this is pretty great
yeah this is cinematic it's cable
quality uh i love it a lot all right
guys what'd you think of the second
episode here
what did we not talk about that you're
angry at us for not talking about leave
your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button check us out on
patreon last but not least
w tongue punch fart box
listen up man it's time for your shout
out and uh i want you
to come meet me at my fortress of
solitude so i can run you through some
tests all right i'm gonna test out that
punch fart box of yours and see if it's
worth
putting against my tongue because that's
the word i left out and that's where
we're headed in this shout out so
buddy i hope you're doing well i hope
you're feeling loved because
we love and appreciate you being here
anyway be well
and uh thank you for your continued
support
and i will see you in the fortress of
solitude my friend
are you aware of like most of what
you're saying when you do these shout
outs
where did you come from i just blacked
out for a minute there